So now we have a simple service.
Wasn't that easy?
But it still doesn't wake itself up.
Fortunately, there's
a system service for that.
This is a good opportunity to
introduce the alarm manager.
The alarm manager allows you to
tell the system that you want it to
wake a component of your application
up after a period of time and
do some processing in the background.
You can even have it wake up your
application periodically, but
what do we wake up in the background?
That would be an Android
component we haven't seen before,
called a broadcast receiver.
A broadcast receiver is a special
class that is used to receive
intent broadcasts,
often from other applications.
Typically, a broadcast receiver
will register an intent filter for
these broadcasts.
It's also one way the application
will listen in on alarms.
Alarms take advantage of a new kind
of intent, called a PendingIntent.
A PendingIntent is
a special kind of intent
that is handed from one
application to another.
The big difference between
a PendingIntent and a regular intent
is that a PendingIntent gives permission
for the app using it to send data with
the same permissions and application
identity as the app that created it.
In Android this allows the system
process to call your application back
in a specific asynchronous way without
compromising the Android security model.
In alarms a pending intent
is used by the alarm manager
to talk to the broadcast
receiver we create.
Let's add some alarm stuff.
First, I'm going to add
a BroadcastReceiver as a static inner
class of SunshineService.
Since this is an Android component,
I'll register this broadcast
receiver in the manifest.
Note the way a static
inner class is notated.
Okay.
I've given you the bones of a broadcast
receiver that can handle an alarm.
But now it's your turn.
You can create a PendingIntent
from an explicit intent
to have the alarm manager
activate your broadcast receiver.
I recommend setting the alarm
to something absurdly short,
like five seconds, so
you can easily test that it's working.